hey guys welcome to a brand new video uh
today is going to be another kind of
random uh money maker I just kind of
stumbled upon now before I get into this
I just want to state that this is more
just for entertainment purposes I do not
think this is actually a genuine Money
Maker it's just a oneoff opportunity but
I thought i' would make a video of it
just cuz I find it interesting and I
hope you guys do as well uh so let me
know but um yeah so what I have found
today for you guys is uh the mythal
crossbow actually has been selling for
an outrageous amount of money
occasionally but if we go down to the
day graph right now we're on G tracker
right now uh it looks like it's selling
for 8K uh so we're going to go ahead and
check the um items that are required to
make the mythro crossbow okay so we have
the wiki open here uh now the myth
crossbow is used for a diary requirement
I'm pretty sure that's why it is a
desirable item so what we need is a
maple stock uh mithil crossbow Limbs and
a crossbow string uh so I don't think
any of will run us too much now I'm just
going to try to do uh well let's price
check this first here so uh let's start
with the maple stock uh very random
item uh we bought it for 10 GP perfect
uh
mythal
[Music]
limbs bought that for 500 and last of
all uh we need the crossbow string this
one shouldn't be an issue
and take that back I have to buy a
little bit higher okay so we bought all
the components now I think you just have
to put the stock on there need a hammer
all right we'll just withdraw a hammer
quickly stock onto the limbs perfect
string onto the mythal crossbow perfect
now let's go ahead and price check one
of these things mythal crossbow now
hopefully we can actually buy for the
10K amount uh 7660 yeah that looks great
so uh and let's just instant sell it and
see what it sells
for uh 698 so this might be kind of a
oneoff opportunity but let's give this a
try so I'm going to go ahead and
withdraw exactly uh 1 mil and what I'm
going to do is do maybe just a couple
hundred I know I could do this for like
an hour but I don't think there's going
to be a point of doing that so we have a
look at the day graph here I mean it
does trade but like let's see now it's
12:00 pretty well uh so pretty much in
12 hours it's traded
like I would say like 50 to 100 roughly
uh so not a whole lot but we'll do 200
of these and see if we can sell it over
the next day uh so let's go ahead and
put an offer in for the mythal mythal
limbs we're going to put them in for 1K
because we don't need to be super uh
time efficient here so we'll do 1K of
these so 200k we're investing bought
them all perfect bought them all for 500
not bad Maple stock and we'll buy by 200
of
these and last up is the crossbow string
200 of these so we actually instab
bought all of the components which is
awesome only cost us about 200k for all
of it so let's go ahead and start making
the uh crossbows okay so I pretty much
added all these stocks to the mythal
limbs uh on top of the money I'm going
to make I actually got about
115k Fletching experience per hour which
isn't bad uh to make all of these limbs
it took about uh minutes uh which is not
very long so now all I have to do is add
the crossbow strings to them and then we
will be done so I guess I should get the
experience for this as well and I'm
going to get actually less weird anyway
uh it's about the same rate so it should
be another 6 minutes to add the strings
to the crossbows and I'll come back when
we're all done okay so we just finished
up adding all the strings to the
crossbows this will be the last five uh
spe per hour not as good but only took
about another 6 minutes so let's round
this off to say it took 15 minutes in
total to uh get all the ingredients for
the crossbows and create uh 200 missile
crossbows looks like I already had two
interestingly enough and we had 88k
which accidentally deposited okay so now
the moment of truth how much can I sell
these for I'm just going to go recheck
the price once again just in
case and 10K we're looking to sell them
for like
7K wow we're
not we didn't even manage to buy one so
I think we can sell them for whatever
whatever we want I'm going to go with $
6999 just an arbitrary number people who
need actually I don't know people who
need this item will need this item we'll
go for
$74.99 so all 200 are going to sell for
1.5 mil now I don't expect this to sell
very quickly I'm not sure how many of
these I'm going to sell but I'm going to
leave this for a day or two I check back
in and see uh how many I managed to
sell okay so all of the mythal crossbows
have sold uh it was a bit of a challenge
to get them all uh to sell but I'll
explain what happened so I started off
by trying to sell them for 6.5k each now
I would pretty consistently get undercut
by people uh which is fine but uh the
reason I ended up actually reducing the
price is because I could tell someone
was flipping them and and it undercut me
uh if it was just someone undercutting
at like 500 GP trying to sell off their
myle crossbow that's fine they'll sell
out quickly but someone actively
flipping them uh could take days uh for
them all to sell out so I started this
flip on the 17th of May and is the 19th
now uh so we sold let's see here 57 of
them for 6.5k each another 63 of them
for 6K each and the last 80 for 5.2k
each uh so let's go claim all the money
we had 808k and if you recall we started
with uh 1 mil exactly and we finished at
uh pretty much a 1 1 mil profit which is
great only took me 15 minutes to make
the crossbows and a couple days to sell
them off now the reason that this was
successful is mainly because there's
still a demand for it this wouldn't work
with any old item uh cuz I mean any item
you could buy out the entire stock of it
if it's not traded very much and then
put your own price in uh but that's not
going to work if people don't actually
need it for this it's a diary item uh
and people will need it eventually so it
works pretty well it would work with
Quest items but mainly I just did this
because uh the price was already like
that I don't think I would put the work
into artificially trying to buy out the
stock uh so then I could put my own
price I don't think that' be worth it uh
but just so happens that the price was
at like 7K each and I took advantage of
it so it looks like I managed to make
970k so about a m uh in a couple days of
selling them off and only 15 minutes of
making the crossbows so again this is
not meant to be a moneymaking guide more
just a uh record of how I made uh this
money cuz I think it's cool to find
little uh Trends and little bubbles of
items you can flip or things you can do
and I hope you guys did as well so
thanks for watching guys and I'll see
you guys in the next video